so we're told that f of x is equal to x
over one minus cosine of x minus two and
there's and they ask us to select the
correct description of the one-sided
limits of f at x equals two and we see
that right at x equals 2 if we try to
evaluate
f of 2
we get 2 over 1 minus cosine of 2 minus
2 which is the same thing as cosine of 0
and cosine of 0 is just 1 and so 1 minus
1 is 0 and so the function is not
defined at x equals 2 and that's why it
might be interesting to find the limit
as x approaches 2 and especially the
one-sided limits and at the one side
limits well well i'll just leave it at
that so let's let's try to approach this
and there's there's actually a couple of
ways you could do it there's one way you
could do this without a calculator by
just inspecting what's going on here and
thinking about the properties of the
cosine function and if that inspires you
pause the video and work it out and i
will do that at the end of this video
the other way if you have a calculator
is to do it with to is to do it with a
little bit of a table like we've done in
other example problems so if we think
about x
approaching 2 from the positive
direction well then
we can make a little table here
where you have x and then you have f of
x
and so for approaching 2 from values
greater than 2
you could have 2.1
2.01
now the reason why i said calculators
these aren't trivial to evaluate because
this would be
what
2.1 over 1 minus cosine of 2.1 minus 2
is
0.1
i do not know what cosine of 0.1 is
without a calculator i do know that
cosine of 0 is one so this is very very
close to one without getting to one and
it's going to be less than one cosine is
never going to be greater than one the
cosine function is bounded between
negative one is less than
cosine of x i'll just write the x there
i don't need the parentheses which is
less than 1. the cosine
the cosine function just oscillates
between these two values so this this
thing is going to be approaching 1 but
it's going to be less than 1. it
definitely cannot be greater than 1. and
that's actually a good hint for how you
can just explore the structure here and
then you could say all right 2.01 well
that's going to be 2.01 over 1 minus
cosine of
0.01
and this is going to be even closer to 1
without being 1. so this could you know
this is but it's going to be less than
1. no matter what cosine of anything is
going to be less than it's going to be
between negative 1 and 1 and it could
even be including those things but as we
approach as we approach 2 this thing is
going to approach it's going to approach
1 i guess you could say approach 1 from
below and so you can start to make some
intuitions here if it's approaching 1
from below
this thing over here this whole
expression is going to be positive
and as we approach x equals 2 well the
numerator is positive it's approaching 2
the denominator is positive so this
whole thing has to be approaching a
positive value or it could become
unbounded in the positive direction as
we'll see this is unbounded because
this thing
is even closer to 1 than this thing and
you would see that if you have a
calculator but needless to say this is
going to be unbounded in the positive
direction so we're going to be going
towards positive infinity so these two
choices have that and we can make the
exact same argument as we go as we
approach x
in the negative or from below as we
approach 2 from below i should say
so that's x
and that is f of x and once again i
don't have a calculator in front of me
you could evaluate these things with a
calculator it'll become very clear that
these are positive and as we get closer
to they become
even larger and larger positive values
and the same thing would happen if you
did 1.9
and
1.9 and if you did
and if you did 1.99
because here you'd be 1.9 over 1 minus
cosine
now here you'd have 1.9 minus 2 so this
would be negative 0.1
let me scroll over a little bit
this second one would be 1.99
over 1 minus cosine
of negative 0.01 0.01
and cosine of negative 0.1 is the same
thing as cosine of 0.1 cosine of
negative
0.01 is the same thing as cosine of 0.01
so these two things this is going to be
equivalent to that that is going to be
equivalent to that and once again we're
going to be approaching positive
infinity so the only choice whether all
of that is true is this first one
whether you approach
whether we approach 2 from the
right-hand side or the left-hand side we
are approaching positive infinity now
the other way you could have deduced
that is say okay as we approach 2 the
numerator is going to be positive
because 2 is positive and then over here
as you approach 2 cosine of anything can
never be greater than 1. it's going to
approach 1 but be less than 1.
so if this is less than 1 as x
approaches 2 it becomes 1 when x is
equal to 2 well then this right over
here 1 minus something less than 1 is
going to be positive so you have a
positive divided by positive so you're
definitely going to get positive values
as you approach two and we know or and
they've already told us that these are
going to be unbounded based on the
choices so you would you would also pick
that but you should also feel good about
it that the closer that we get to two
the closer that this value right over
here gets to
zero and the closer that this value gets
to zero the closer we get to one the
closer we get to one
the smaller the denominator gets and
then you divide by smaller and smaller
denominators you're going to become
unbounded towards infinity which is
exactly what we see in that first choice